okay so the topic of this video today is
going to be on one of the categories of
organic molecules called nucleic acids
now just to refresh our memory here are
the organic molecule categories all of
them carbohydrates lipids proteins and
nucleic acids I have a separate video
for each of these but this video
specifically looks at nucleic acids so
let's get started so you're often going
to hear nucleic acids such as DNA being
compared to a blueprint well here's a
blueprint of a boat you know a blueprint
is a construction manual basically if
you have an engineering background you
could follow this blueprint and
construct the boat well nucleic acids
are instructions as well
they are instructions they're coded
instructions and they tell your cells
and particularly they tell your
ribosomes which are a part of your cell
they tell your ribosomes to build
proteins now how that process actually
works we'll discuss in a separate video
if you want you can search through my
library I have a video titled
translation and in that video I
discussed the process but for now we're
just going over some some some general
details so proteins are what DNA and RNA
the nucleic acids are blueprints to
build eventually they will tell your
cells how to build proteins so there's
two types of nucleic acids I just
mentioned these a moment ago DNA and RNA
we're going to go into more details on
each of them in a few moments but you
can see from the picture that DNA is
what we call a double helix and RNA is
simply a single strand more on more in
these details in a few moments well as
I've said with all the other organic
molecule videos nucleic acids are an
organic molecule and they're made from
smaller organic molecules so a monomer
is a small part of an organic molecule
and so the monomer of a nucleic acid is
what is called a nucleotide but when one
nucleotide binds with another with
another with another it makes a larger
object
called a nucleic acid so monomers bond
to make polymers and in the world of
nucleic acids the monomer is called a
nucleotide and the polymer is a nucleic
app so when we look at the monomer
called a nucleic acid in a little more
detail you know what's a nucleotide well
it's a monomer of a nucleic acid but
let's look at the molecular structure in
a little more detail if we kind of just
isolate one nucleic excuse me if we
isolate one nucleotide and then zoom on
in we'll often I see it in a very
simplistic diagram or drawing that kind
of looks like this so there are three
parts to the structure of a nucleotide
you're often going to see a Pentagon
shaped symbol and that represents the
sugar molecule now here in the bottom
picture this is the actual molecular
formula of the sugar that makes up DNA
now I hope you can see why it's often
just kind of shown as a Pentagon in
various diagrams that you might see
another part labeled P in the top
picture is called the phosphate group
and in the bottom picture you can see
why it's called the phosphate group
first of all group because there's a
group of atoms and phosphate because
it's centered around phosphorus and so
it's very very often in diagrams online
in textbooks in in this presentation
you're going to see simply the phosphate
group shown as just a circle and in the
top picture you can see it's just a
black circle with the letter P in it and
then we come to the unique portion of a
nucleotide the final part of a
nucleotide is made up of a nitrogen base
now there are four possible nitrogen
bases and you can see the letter
abbreviations for each so right now with
the in the green box in the top right
hand corner there's a letter a that
stands for a molecule called adenine
there's three other nitrogen bases there
is a nitrogen base labeled T which
stands for thiamine there's a nitrogen
base labeled C which stands for cytosine
there's a nitrogen base labeled G which
stands for guanine in
there's actually a fifth nitrogen base
called uracil with stand with
abbreviated with the letter U
that's an RNA nucleotide we'll talk
about that later the four that you see
right here these are DNA nucleotide and
so what we're going to show you a moment
or what I showed you earlier with the
simplistic orange circles connecting to
one another and here's a nucleotide
nucleotides combine to make larger
polymers remember the polymer is called
a nucleic acid so one nucleotide will
bond with a wide variety of others to
make larger nucleic acid so if we were
in class I would give you a minute to
talk with your neighbor and try to work
out these five questions you know at
home right now pause the video and I'm
going to go over these answers in three
two one okay so now that you've had time
to pause the video and try to answer
these on your own question number one
how many nucleotides are pictured well
if you discount the a's t CS and GS i
hope you see there are six of them
number two all tall or what would this
long chain of nucleotides be called well
a whole collection of nucleotides is
called a nucleic acid number three name
the blue shaped Pentagon molecule that
typically the Pentagon shaped molecule
is going to be the sugar there's three
parts to a nucleotide a sugar a
phosphate and a nitrogen base the
Pentagon shaped one it's going to be the
sugar number four what are these
individual monomers called the
individual parts the six individual
parts that make up the overall nucleic
acid well there's a clue in number one
it says how many nucleotides are
pictured well those individual monomers
are called nucleotides and number five
what will these instructions be used to
create nucleic acids in general our
instructions to tell your cells how to
build a protein so let's move on so when
we look at specifically the nucleic acid
called DNA we will talk about RNA in a
few moments but DNA in particular you're
going to often hear the shape called a
double helix and in the animation a
helix simply means like a spiral
staircase a spiral
arrangement of a spiral ladder if you
imagine that in your mind and so double
because there's going to be two strands
of nucleotides a strand on the left the
Strand on the right you'll see what I
mean in just a moment so here is a
simplistic drawing of a strand of
nucleotides on the left and a strand of
nucleotides on the right this is what we
mean by the double in the word double
helix now I don't have in this in this
drawing here they're not twisted that
you know they'd be a little too tricky
to do with with you know PowerPoint but
you can see the double part of a double
helix and what holds those two strands
together what holds the left strand what
holds the right strand together are what
are called hydrogen bonds there's a
hydrogen bond in between the C and the G
on top there's a hydrogen bond in
between the a and the T on top and so on
as you go down and so one of the things
that was being uncovered in the early
part of the 1900s was the structure of
DNA and there was a scientist an
Austrian scientist by the name of our
one shark F who discovered that the
amount of adenine was always equal to
the amount of thymine and for years we
didn't really know why but now we do the
reason the amount of adenine a is equal
to the amount of thymine T is because
they pair with one another and the
second observation the erwin chargaff
noticed was that the amount of G for
guanine was always equal to the amount
of C for cytosine and for years we
didn't really understand why and then it
was discovered that guanine and cytosine
G and C were bonded together so that's
why they were always appearing in equal
numbers so when we look at this picture
again we can see from top to bottom
anytime there's a C on the left there's
a G on the right anytime there's an A on
the Left there's a T on the right a
pairs with T C pairs with G these are
called chargon chargaff's rule and so
one thing I also want to mention is that
DNA is mate genes excuse me genes are
made of DNA I'm sure you've heard of
genes
genetics you studied you know dominant
genes and recessive genes and autosomal
dominant autosomal recessive and well so
a gene is a portion it's a small chunk
of DNA that will eventually tell your
cell your ribosome in your cell how to
make a protein so for instance here's a
big chain of DNA in this picture for
instance let me just highlight that
small area right there pretend that's
gene a that combination of a T CS and
G's those count that combination of A's
t CS and G's will ultimately tell your
ribosomes how to make a protein for
instance maybe that sequence right there
tells your ribosome how to make a
protein called hemoglobin you know
here's another gene that I just
highlighted gene B that little sequence
of a's t's c's and g's eventually holds
in the instructions to make a protein
called keratin and the ribosome will
receive these instructions then make up
and make the protein called keratin in
the last example let's highlight gene C
so that chunk of DNA right there pretend
is gene C C you can see that some genes
are bigger some genes are smaller and so
pretend that gene C is is the code the
set of instructions that eventually will
tell your ribosome to make a protein
called collagen so how the ribosome
makes a protein is not something we're
going to discuss in this video but if
you want to look through my library of
videos it's a process called translation
I have a video on that you can check out
at your convenience so if we just kind
of take a stand back for a moment and
you know pause the video and try to
answer this question how many
nucleotides do you see in this picture
I'm going to show the answer in three
two one
so a nucleotide remember is one
combination of a sugar phosphate and
nitrogen base and so I just highlighted
the end so there's twelve of them
there's six on the Left connected by
hydrogen bonds two six on the right
so what about the other kind of nucleic
acid ribonucleic acid well ribonucleic
acid from the picture you can see is a
bit different from DNA DNA if you recall
is the double helix the twists and
spiral-shaped
staircase RNA is
it's a single chain of nuclei
nucleotides and so it's still a
combination of nucleotides so remember
nucleotide is a sugar a phosphate a
nitrogen base but notice how there is a
different nitrogen base there's still a
for adenine C for cytosine and G for
guanine but in the world of RNA there is
no t4 thiamine you have a different
nitrogen base the letter U stands for
the nitrogen base by the name of Europe
and so in general this is very in
general here the the general purpose of
RNA is to deliver information from from
a DNA molecule to a ribosome on the left
is a DNA helix and remember we said that
DNA is the instructions to build a
protein well the problem is that the
ribosome is the actual physical builder
of the protein so that in the
instructions of DNA has to somehow get
to the ribosome the ribosome cannot
begin building a protein until it has
the instructions so the molecule that
goes in between the two is a type of RNA
by the name of messenger RNA so
messenger RNA will copy a piece of the
instructions of DNA take it over to the
ribosome and once the ribosome has the
instructions then the ribosome can live
up to its job the job of a ribosome is
to build proteins and then release the
proteins to wherever they are needed so
that's a very quick simplistic overview
of what of what RNA does again what
we'll go into more of this in detail
later on the school year in another
video so how do nucleotides bind
together how does a nuclear how does one
nucleotide on top bond to a nucleotide
on the bottom how do small molecules
bond to make large amount like heels I
hope you know that's the answer of
dehydration synthesis watch this in a
dehydration synthesis reaction I've
highlighted h2o in red so it stands out
more visually so here we have two
nucleotides so when they're bonded
together like
water will be removed and with the help
of enzymes those bonds will be broken
and the two nucleotides will bond
together with one another so again
dehydration synthesis is a way to the
end is a way there that larger molecules
are built up from smaller molecules and
in the process water is removed so kind
of the opposite here we have a larger
nucleic acid what process would break
these apart the answer i hope you know
is hydrolysis we talked about
dehydration synthesis and hydrolysis and
other videos so hydrolysis simply means
the addition of water hydro implies
water lysis is a word that simply means
to break so water and various enzymes
are going to help to break the bonds
that are holding those two nucleic acids
together and so there you have a
hydrolysis reaction where where the two
individual nucleotides have been
separated so here we have a kind of just
a summary table you know if we were in
class one minute discuss this with your
neighbor try to figure out what word
goes in box ABCD and E pause the video
think about it I'm going to go over the
answers in three two one so if you've
watched these videos in order nucleic
acids are the final organic molecule
that we're going to discuss so here's a
just a summary table the monomer of a
carbohydrates called a monosaccharide
the polymer of a carbohydrate is called
a polysaccharide in proteins the monomer
of a protein is called in the Meno acid
in lipids the monomer of a lipid it's
actually two fatty acids are one of the
monomers as is the molecule called
glycerol a fatty acid and a glycerol
bond to make a lipid which is the
polymer and the last one which what we
discussed in this video today a
nucleotide is the monomer and a bunch of
nucleotides bond to make a polymer by
the name of a nucleic acid so there you
have it if you're one of my students you
know pause the video and try to answer
these on a separate sheet of paper I'd
be happy
to check your answers before school or
after school good luck